they don't realize that productivity is
not about working more hours it's about
what you put in the hours so and what's
crazy is part of the book talks about
you can't get to seven figures doing
more of what got you six figures
recording remote interviews for your
podcast has never been easier with
podcastle
share your link with up to nine
different guests and they can
immediately start recording using their
own computers with no additional
equipment or downloads required with
each guest on their own locally recorded
studio quality track editing is a breeze
too you can split trim fade and arrange
each track to your heart's content then
use podcasts ai powered magic desk tool
to automatically sweeten and equalize
the mix you can invite record edit and
polish it's all in a day's work with
podcasts start recording your podcast
for free at podcastwiththink.com
what is up sean cannell here and let me
ask you a question
are you ready to double the results
you're getting on youtube and in your
online business i know that's a crazy
almost sensational claim but the truth
is when you apply the right principles
and levers
to your youtube channel to your business
to your activities everything can change
i know it because it personally happened
to me with the content that you're going
to be learning in this episode
and today we have a guest and his name
is peter voog and he's been on a couple
think media podcast episodes in fact if
you've loved having peter on and you're
watching on youtube drop a comment if
you've been getting value out of any of
these if you haven't reviewed the
podcast that would mean the world to me
whether it's this episode or others
you've been getting value today's the
day friend you're like man i've been
listening i've heard heather say review
the podcast i've heard sean say it
today's the day let us know what you
think on apple podcast but if you're
just meeting peter he's been recognized
by entrepreneur.com is the world's
leading authority for millennials and
entrepreneurs he wrote a book called six
months to six figures and it sold over
500 000 copies which is just crazy and
his new book seven rolls to seven
figures has been crushing it its
subtitle is the entrepreneur's playbook
to freedom family and fortune and my
favorite f in there actually is the
family f that he had there beyond the
different things peter's built he's
built up seven figures in real estate
direct selling uh in in uh education and
a lot of different industries but he's
done it by having family as one of his
highest values we share a similar value
that we want to experience success
without losing our soul with values
intact with family intact with faith
intact so let's get into it
[Music]
welcome back to the think media podcast
we have peter vuk back on the show and
i'm super excited about this episode
because we're going to be talking about
how to double your youtube and online
business growth
guaranteed now before you jump off you
might say how can you possibly guarantee
that but the truth is
it's possible and if you're ready to
actually double your results and make
sure that you're spending your time on
the right things peter's going to be
sharing some powerful principles that
will boost your views boost subscribers
boost sales boost revenue if you apply
them and uh it's all about profit
maximizers and the 80 20 rule and so
peter let's dive into it but you know
some people the 80 20 rule the pareto
principle
um is is maybe something that not
everyone's familiar with so let's let's
start there what is that so it is the
principle that the majority of things
that you do
actually don't move the needle in your
life and business and they've done
countless studies like years and years
of studies in science and i've seen it
true for my business where if there's 10
activities you're doing
two of those activities yield results
more than 80 other percent over the
other eight activities so i'm always 80
20 and sometimes 90 tenning things where
if i have 10 things i'm doing usually
one or two yield higher results than all
the other ones so the goal is figuring
out what the 80 20 is in your business
and what's actually moving the needle
and getting results it even goes in
every area of life like usually the
amount of people that you connect with
there's like 20 of the people you talk
to are causing 80 of your unhappiness
and frustration and toxicity so it goes
from people business success finances
wealth action steps results youtube it's
never been proven wrong so that's why
it's so important yeah i i mean i think
i heard it said like in a city
uh 20 percent of the traffic uh or 80 of
the traffic drives on 20 of the roads
which makes sense because that's all the
traffic's on those main highways and
then there's the back streets and no
one's on those streets and so you define
it here the 80 20 rules 20 of all your
activities account for 80 percent of
your income so if you apply just that
that means that actually there's a lot
of things you need to stop doing and if
you identify the things that are winning
in your life your business your youtube
channel double down on those you're
gonna start getting more
leverage now i want to talk about profit
maximizers in just a second but i like
how you define productivity here i
haven't read anything like this anywhere
before but you redefine productivity and
so here's how you define productivity
getting
the result that you want peter i think
some people think that productivity
maybe isn't even about results it's
about busyness have you seen that oh for
sure i think a lot of businesses hide
hide behind the mask of like
busyness and
doing things more time that takes more
time and spending all their time working
and they don't realize that productivity
is not about working more hours it's
about what you put in the hours so and
what's crazy is part of the book talks
about you can't get to seven figures
doing more of what got you six figures
so sometimes if you want to double your
subscribers you can't just do more of
what gotchu your other subscribers it's
a different way of thinking and a
different mentality so it's really just
understanding productivity about getting
the result you want and i'll tell you
sean i work less hours now than i was
making six figures it's not about the
hours you work and people are so
obsessed with activity like henry
thoreau says it's like
you're busy but so are the ants the
question is busy doing what yeah and now
that i have kids i have 202. i can't be
busy being busy
because i'm killing my family time so
now i i take it personal where it's like
if i'm busy being busy my family suffers
so instead of working all the time i
told myself i will be disciplined
instead of working all the time that's
productivity
man that's so powerful and one of the
biggest concepts that i want to get into
is you know this idea of ipas income
producing activities
you call them profit maximizers you know
having a results ritual and uh you know
one of the things that actually really
shifted my life especially over the last
couple years was listen listening to
your mixtapes so i listen to them on
spotify uh you've got you know these
motivational and even just tactical
and and i would hear you you know maybe
i listen to this track a couple times
and you would always say like are you
focusing
on your ipas
not the beer right it's not it's not not
the indian pale ale but on your income
producing activities and that just
started to shift my thinking to evaluate
myself to say
am i getting up and just
spending extra long editing a video a
couple years ago or
uh just researching by looking at
swiping on on instagram when i don't
need to research more
you know studying the competition when
really i'm just avoiding the hard work i
need to do or am i actually doing the
things that move the needle furthermore
am i doing something that moves the
needle to earn a few dollars through
affiliate marketing or am i doing the
hard work of creating a book or creating
a course that can instead of making four
percent from amazon affiliate marketing
i can make 98 in an online course that i
create that i own
harder decisions that actually produce
income and peter that
pro affected us so profoundly here at
think media that actually uh on our team
meetings now in slack we have meetings
three days a week monday wednesday and
friday where we get on zoom but every
single day at 9 00 a.m or about 8 45
myself or heather or mel we post the
question hey good morning think team
post your ipas every single day your ip
and that doesn't mean what do you have
because there's other things you have to
do some things you have to do
just for maintenance to keep things
going but those should be delegated
if that's let's get into that
but but ipas would be like what are we
actually doing that's producing income
and if it's not then why are we even
doing it because and you you have to be
unashamed about this in business right
because cash flow is oxygen to a
business you need money for the mission
so are you doing things that actually
generate results on youtube am i
actually making the right video
two of your ten videos are actually you
could probably know ahead of you do
youtube videos long enough you know
which ones are actually going to do well
why are you even making the other eight
focus on the topics that actually
produce the biggest results and so this
is profit maximizers i want you to
expound on this but you said this
powerful sentence the amount of stress
you have in your life
is in direct correlation to the lack of
results and systems you have in place
i mean first of all avoidance is
addictive
so i i i study entrepreneur businesses
we have an academy where i help people's
businesses
and me and my business partner are
always diving in and trying to figure
out what what the difference is between
these businesses thriving and the ones
struggling and almost always it's never
who works more hours which is weird
it's always the people who are who are
doing the most that are avoiding the
hard things that actually get them
results usually if you have 40 hours of
work or 50 hours of work to do
the work that you're avoiding or that
you don't feel like doing is usually the
one that moves the needle that we have
to attack first and almost do that first
when you have the most willpower in the
morning so i did the same thing with my
team sean where i had them always give
me what's their most important movable
move
moving the needle activities no edits
that actually get them results and the
reality is they didn't usually do those
things so i think that's the important
is shift from complexity to simplicity
there's 20 10 or 20 percent of things
that get you the biggest results and
your job as a ceo or an entrepreneur is
to figure what those are figure out what
those are and once you figure those out
you almost have an unfair advantage in
business so that's why i brought that up
is people that don't have systems in
place or don't have result focused
activities they're always just churning
their wheels and eventually they get
burnt out and they start resenting
things they're good at and they
eventually quit
that's why this is so powerful so it's
like there's many ways to figure it out
you can look back in the last
year of your business where did most of
your customers come from yeah right you
can focus on one of the biggest profit
producers is understanding marketing is
the game where there's producing there's
creating then there's marketing of the
doing
so a lot of people spend 80 90 on
producing of the actual doing they're
like oh i got a course it's the best
course i got this i got this i got the
title i got the cover the course all the
materials they're focused on the on the
actual thing
they don't focus on the marketing of the
thing
so they'll have a perfect course that
has no customers so i would recommend
spending 80 or 90 of your time on the
marketing of the doing marketing of the
course yeah that's one of your top
profit maximizers because when you have
marketing more people know about your
product they buy yep so i see people
nowadays there's some even people that
that i know that are in the academy that
i've helped they create like so many
videos they have they do two videos a
week one has one view one has three
views one is six views it's like dude
push that
don't just keep producing without
marketing the production of what you're
doing yeah that's a 80 20 thing so it's
just understanding what moves the needle
what gets results in your industry and
then going all in on that and then
another thing i talk about too is growth
activities versus maintenance activities
whereas as a ceo or as someone that is
the visionary of the company or you're
starting out even if you're you're a
little bit newer you shouldn't be doing
too much of the maintenance
of the
of the things that have to happen every
week regardless you should be focused on
the growth activities that push the
business forward the results activities
and everything else should be delegated
and handled and systemized so i i feel
like a lot of people still try and do
everything themselves
and that that's going to kill their
productivity imagine if you did every
single thing in your business sure you'd
be overwhelmed and you wouldn't be at
your best in anything sure that's what
people are doing and if you're not
growing you are dying 100 because if
you're not if you're not on offense
taking ground you'd be losing ground and
so you have to be disciplined and
diligent to delegate those things
so duplicate yourself here's some ideas
on some profit producing activities and
this is what i've learned it's funny you
bring up that we're sometimes afraid of
doing the
the harder things you know of course
we're here to help you build your
youtube channel which is a good
investment of your time because it's the
marketing it gives you eventually uh
like dig your well before you're thirsty
a raving fans a fan base a channel for
all your future whatever it is you want
to market your services your book a
course uh one on one we have so many
real estate agents you want more clients
you want more leads so your youtube
channel could be that however if you're
doing freak organic content you also
know it's going to take time so
sometimes there's the hard things you
need to do today
to actually keep income flowing while
you're potentially digging your well for
tomorrow which could be your youtube
channel and in our inner circle program
i was talking to somebody and they were
kind of struggling on their channel just
wasn't growing that fast or leading to
clients yet and i said okay fair enough
but i said how many clients do you need
a month
and he goes well i need about two i need
two clients a month and i was like two
clients a month like 10 15 phone calls
yeah i was like how about you just get
on the phone like just get somebody put
a story on your instagram or only have a
couple hundred instagram followers
that's enough just say hey would you
like to work together said you know
click yes or no or whatever in a survey
there or tap into your linkedin audience
but that's harder that takes rejection
that's uncomfortable yeah that's why
they don't do it that's right and he was
like shoot he was like i like i kind of
like shooting these videos and editing
these videos
and just lobbing them out there and
hoping something happens
that's good too but you need to do your
ipas first because once you're paid now
you have fuel to keep going and so
here's some uh ideas here you give
making sales calls yeah getting on the
phone inviting someone to be on the
phone dm'ing somebody not in a spammy
way but really working with tap into
linkedin or instagram or somewhere else
talking to your sales people
writing and creating content
reaching out to companies or developing
partnerships that's huge right they're
creating the course if they built some
relationships with a couple jv's joint
vet
venture partners already that you could
lead to tons of sales but you're just
sitting there waiting for people to come
to you they're probably never going to
come to you making appointments or even
going door to door when necessary well
that's scary
uh send an emails to your contact list
peter i can't tell you how many times we
incur we actually have so many success
students they get their youtube channel
going they're they they create something
really valuable they're giving it away
their email list is growing we then say
how often do you email them
uh i don't i just got so much to do i
have an email like well that's what's
the point of the list
you know and that's probably one of
their highest value activities is
emailing them because that's what those
are the people who've actually gone to
that level of depth to trust you with
their contact information to join you
there who have also
your free gift has polarized that
audience you know exactly why they
signed up because they want more
information about that
and uh you could be emailing but here's
the lesson this is a great point you
don't have to be emailing them you can
hire a copywriter one of the biggest
breakthroughs i had from six to seven
figures is when i think about something
i have to do it's like who can i hire
who can do this that this is their
expertise they love this and it's not my
strength
versus like what stops a lot of people
sean is they don't think they're good at
that
so if you want to get to the seven
figure mark even the six figure mark you
have to start thinking in terms of
hiring and training and developing
people versus you doing everything you
should only be doing your five percent
genius and whatever you do
the best with the least amount of effort
is your gift if you can work in your
gift
life is so much more enjoyable and you
grow exponentially that's when you start
doubling and tripling your subscribers
your sales your success ipas man a
couple others creating persuasive copy
working on your delivery to sell more
from stage that could also be working on
or practicing your delivery of a web
class or something you're doing creating
your marketing messaging messaging in
general you teach a lot on that like
just if you dial in your messaging so
that it cuts through the noise your
branding and positioning you can check
out the episode we did with uh peter on
that definitely check out the show notes
uh and creating a referral system for
your business sheesh that's its whole
own thing you start getting referrals
activated so the big idea of today's
episode are what are your ipas what are
the profit maximizers in your business
what are the top performing videos top
performing social media pieces of
content if you haven't been studying
your data instagram shows us in our
insights it tells you what your top
posts are you want to double down and
constantly be i like that you said it
it's not just the 80 20 rule once it's
then the 80 20 of the 80 20 of the 80 20
that's a lifestyle of continuous
optimization to the highest performing
products highest performing email
subject lines highest performing
youtube videos and so uh what are your
ipas wherever you're if you're on
youtube definitely drop us a comment of
what you would say today what is your
biggest income generating activity that
you could double down on and uh if you
have been listening to any of these
episodes
with peter we've had him on the podcast
a couple times now talking about some
content from his new book seven rules to
seven figures
we'd love it if you would leave a review
on apple
podcasts and let us know if you're
getting value out of the think media
podcast and even maybe one of the game
changing mindset shifting insights that
you've taken out of this series um but
income producing activities man focus on
what moves the needle peter uh where can
people get the book and uh how can
people connect with you thank you so
much sevenrulesbook.com i'm all over
social media instagram uh youtube they
can follow me there and if they hear
about me from this interview definitely
reach out and i'll be happy to help in
any way i can we also dive into my
favorite
six or seven profit maximizers and like
actual productivity profit uh i guess
value ads that you can do to add value
to your customers and clients so i think
that's one of my favorite parts of the
book too if they check it out is like
those actual tactics of what they can do
to become more valuable not just make
more money but understand how to 80 20
everything they do
it's just now that i have kids man my
time is everything so being able to
produce more have a better business
more fulfillment a happier more exciting
life and work less it's just like it
almost feels like i've hacked the system
but it's just from this chapter
man i love it thank you so much peter
for coming on again and adding so much
value check out the book check out
peter's uh channels and we'll see you on
the next episode
of the think media podcast
okay before you do anything i want you
to kind of sit down maybe pull your car
over you know tell fufu to sit if you're
walking your dog open up the notes app
on your phone and let's actually put
some of these tactics into practice
what are the 20 of videos on your
youtube channel that are getting 80 of
the views that are generating 80 of the
subscribers what are those videos what
are the topics about what are the titles
what are the commonalities between their
thumbnails between the aspects of those
videos that you can double down on
the truth is like you might make you're
gonna make 10 new youtube videos over
the next 10 weeks aren't you
now wouldn't it be powerful if instead
of just making 10 videos and eight of
them do okay if you really focus in on
the ones that are driving results now
even more important what is actually
coming into your bank account this month
where does the money come from in your
business maybe you're just starting so
maybe it's still a paycheck or a w-2 but
where is if even if it's a trickle even
if it's just some money from affiliate
marketing or some money from brand deals
or whatever it is identify the 20
and stop doing stop focusing on the 80
and double down i hope you got value out
of this episode and i recommend if you
want you know even more levers like this
peter is so obsessed that's why we we
vibe this is why we jive is because we
love optimizing things we want to work
on things that move the needle we want
to say hey if i only got you know eight
hours in a day how can i use those eight
hours
the most strategically and inside of his
new book you'll be able to get tons of
tactics and tools to help you do that
you know for the cost of a book 15 bucks
or eight bucks for the e-book or
whatever um it's really a no-brainer and
so i definitely recommend you check that
out we'll link that up in the show notes
below which brings us to the comment of
the week and hey thank you so much for i
should say review for leading reviews it
does help get the word out about the
podcast you know if you ever have it in
your heart man i love this podcast it
adds a lot of value to my life think
about who you could share this with but
also consider leaving a review and this
one comes from baxter vision and he says
has it all i appreciate that fun and
inspirational content that speaks to
mind body and soul for both your
business and your personal lifestyle
goals so yeah it basically has it all
man i appreciate that and that is our
goal here we hope that you learn
something every week we hope that you
get some motivation and some inspiration
like this is like a cup of coffee for
your online business and your youtube
goals every week and yes we also hope
that you feel this in your
soul
our vision is to help ten thousand
purpose-driven people create a full-time
living doing what they love
while making a difference in the world
with online video and experience that
success
without losing their soul you know i
really believe that if i build the
biggest business or the biggest youtube
channel but i blow up my marriage in the
process that i failed
that if at the end of my life i've built
accolades and i've got a big bank
account but all the relationships around
me are destroyed and that the people
closest to me don't love and respect me
then i believe i've failed and i
actually believe that if i get applause
from the crowds but i don't have that
love and respect for my children man to
me that would mean that i missed it and
i didn't have my priorities straight and
so we also don't go to the extreme of
thinking that wealth or building a
business or that success is something to
be avoided it's just something that
should never be at the cost
of the things that matter most in life
and so hey we hope that you keep getting
fuel for going after your goals but for
also keeping your values and your
priorities in alignment i'm so grateful
that you would actually spend some of
your week listening to the think media
podcast and i just want you to know i
appreciate you i respect you the fact
that you'd invest in something like this
in personal development and personal
growth and leveling up and learning when
you could just be watching squid game
which is also remarkable and and very
entert a little violent though i don't
know if
but but sure enough a very compelling
show and you had to know what all the
buzz was about uh and so
when you could be just binging the
latest netflix show but instead you're
working on your future your business
plan your goals your youtube channel i
just want you to know how to respect
that and i'm grateful for you now's the
time to go get it now's the time to take
action don't stop the episode now and
just see oh cool my brain was tickled
it's time to actually put some calendar
blocks on your calendar shoot that next
video press record take some action and
really move the needle because friend
together we're going to be in the future
with businesses that are making a
difference but it's on the other side of
taking massive action i can't wait to
see you in the next episode of the think
media podcast and until then take care
and we'll talk soon did you hear that
growth video live 2022 is back in person
this is your opportunity to network with
like-minded people just like you to make
friendships to make business
partnerships this is your opportunity to
get in the room you can get your ticket
now at growethvideolive.com
they're going so fast so make sure you
get your ticket right now at
growthvideolive.com